more senator lindsey graham about to
break some news
about who you have invited to your
committee
yeah the day the day of reckoning is
upon us when it comes to crossfire
hurricane
james comey has agreed to appear before
the senate judiciary committee
on september the 30th without a subpoena
i appreciate mr comey coming before the
committee
he will be respectfully treated but ask
hard questions
we're negotiating with mccabe mr mccabe
we're hoping to get him without a
subpoena
time will tell mueller has declined the
invitation of the committee
to appear to explain his report
after the horowitz report he says he
doesn't have enough time
but september the 30th the 30th we'll
have mr comey before the committee and i
look forward to it
you're going to accept that answer from
robert mueller in light of 27 phones we
believe were erased
because everybody accidentally put in
the wrong
passcode repeatedly and by the way i
never heard that that
locks up a phone or erases a phone have
you ever heard about that
i've dropped phones in the ocean i've
actually dropped one in a toilet bowl
once
uh but i never use bleach pit and i've
had to replace
phones because i lose them i've actually
lost phones
yeah it sounds fishy as hell we're going
to ask the people who did their racing
but i'm going to ask the department of
justice and inspector general to look at
this
but i've been telling your viewers for a
long time that we would try to
have an accounting for what happened
with crossfire hurricane
how did it get so off the rails how was
the pfizer court misled
multiple times well that day is coming
i'm proud of our committee
we will also interview the people who
interviewed the sub source
and we're getting to the bottom of what
happened and we'll have a hearing on
september
30th with mr comey and hopefully mr
mccabe will come in he's out
all over the place we've invited strzok
to come he's selling a book
we'll see if mr strzok will come without
a subpoena but i look forward to this
hearing i think it will be important to
the american people
i'd like jim comey to come on my radio
and tv show i'll give him three hours of
radio in an hour on tv
i have a lot of questions now he was
warned that
the dossier was dirty before he signed
the first warrant
that hillary paid for it didn't put that
in the account it does say verified we
now know it's unverifiable
he signed three of them after he signed
that it was verified
in october he told donald trump in
december
the president-elect that it's salacious
and unverified so he lied either in
october or relied in december
and we also know for sure don't we that
the sub source of steel
said no none of this is true in january
of 2017 and comey went on to sign two
more warrants is that a fax senator
well it's the fact that in january of
2017 and march of 2017
the russian sub-source told the fbi that
it was bar
talk hearsay not verified uh we know
that happened now who did the intel
analysts and the case agent tell
we're going to talk to them in the next
week to 10 days
but here's my point i appreciate mr
comey coming in
we've been asking each other a lot of
questions it's about time to ask the
people in charge
what they'll happen that day is coming i
promised your viewers we would get to
this day
and stay tuned a couple of weeks from
now we'll know a lot more
let me ask you a question if if i told
you that
all that i erased my phone because i put
in the wrong password
do you believe that cockamania story
from robert mueller's team because i
don't believe a word of it
well common sense would tell you that
multiple people erasing
phones that are under investigation
is suspicious as hell horowitz is doing
a review of crossfire hurricane
and this could be obstruction of justice
if you
know that your phone is going to be
looked at for investigative purposes
you erase it then you got a problem
we'll see what happens there too
but even though i'm so i don't know what
bleach fit is i know what a hammer is
i've never used a hammer on a phone
i know what a sim card is but that's
about as far as i can't even download an
app
i'll probably drop this one in the
toilet after that charlie why you're not
that's probably why you're not in charge
of investigations yeah that's true
good point all right senator thank you